>>Commentator: We're really excited today
to have Judith Jones, fabulous editor and
author be with us today. She's gonna share
with you her latest cookbook, 'The Pleasures
of Cooking for One' and then you can ask her
any question you might have on your mind.
So please give her a welcome.
[pause]
>>Judith Jones: [unintelligible] Got it.
[laughter]
Word of honor. [laughs]
[pause]
Get in my high chair.
[laughter]
Well you might all ask why a book on cooking
for one. Some people just get a glazed look
in their eyes and say, "All that fuss just
for me. I don't wanna do that."
But I think there are many, many others who
realize that it's more than just cutting down
recipes. It's a whole strategy that you -- that
you've got to make work for yourself. And
once, once you have it in hand I think you'll
find that just going home at the end of the
day and lighting the stove and getting the
garlic sizzling and filling the house with
good smells, that there's something so satisfying
about it.
And I talked a little bit about in my memoir,
'The Tenth Muse' about, about this at the
end of the book after my husband died because
I felt, "I'm not gonna wanna do it just myself.
It's going to be depressing and too many memories"
and he was a great cook and we cooked together.
But it was quite, I found it was quite the
opposite. I found that by honoring myself
and making a ritual of, of a nice dinner every
night, lighting the candles, turning on some
music, giving thanks, that it -- something
in me responded to this.
And I think you'll, you'll really find that
so. That's what I wanna try to convey.
There have been a number of books about cooking
for one, but mostly they're just a reduced
recipe and, as I say, it's strategy.
Now in the first place you don't think one
dish at a time. You think of one dish leading
to another; it's a rhythm through the week.
Think how many times you're gonna be home
and if you bought that little tenderloin of
pork, how many times would you use it in quite
different ways so you're not eating cold pork
all week?
And all, all meats and fish that lend themselves
to, to flavoring in different ways so they,
they don't taste the same on the second round
or the third round.
Note I don't use leftovers 'cause, the word
leftovers 'cause that puts people off. Second
round, third round, reincarnation [laughs]
[laughter]
I think that, that, is kind of the attitude
to have. And so you think through the week
and you, you try to, to keep things varied
if you have just that extra little piece of
meat on your plate and you really don't want
it, incorporate in a nice little salad you're
making for lunch the next day to take to work.
Now you don't have to because you have a wonderful
cafeteria, but I can tell you the Knopf Cafeteria
makes you wanna bring your own lunch. [laughs]
[laughter]
So I almost invariably do unless I'm going
out and that's part of it too.
And it's, in a curious way you don't overstuff
that because you eat what you want and you
put the other thing aside already beginning
to think of "What am I going to do with that?"
My children used to laugh at me and say, "You're
no sooner you and, you and Evan are no sooner
finished one meal then you're thinking of
the next.
Well, it leads to that because it is a very
creative pleasure. It isn't just following
slavishly a recipe, but looking in the fridge,
seeing what you have, seeing what you have
in your freezer, what needs using up, what
combinations would be good and then really
creating something out of those little tidbits,
I call them gold, in the refrigerator. "Cause
it's like, it's like having treasure.
You learn ways not to waste. Now for instance
you have to a get a whole box of mushrooms.
You don't wanna eat mushrooms three times
or four times in one week; so after the second
or third day and they're beginning to look
a little droopy, chop them up, put 'em in
a small pan with some butter, just enough
to get the, the juice out of them and then
put them in a little plastic bag, sealed.
And there you have what the French call Mushroom
Duxelle.
And you can take a little, break off a piece
and put it in a soup, you can put it in an
omelet; anything that needs seasoning. So
your imagination starts going. That's part
of it and then I think having some things,
basic things on hand.
When I make a tomato sauce I make probably
three times as much as I need and put it in
small containers; same with the cream sauce.
I've devised a way now when I have a, a chicken
stock or even if it's a canned stock, you
know you open it and may be use a half a cup
in your sauce and the rest goes to waste.
Put it in an ice tray and then let it freeze,
and then break up the cubes and put them in
little plastic containers; and that way you
can just pull out one cube and plop it into
your, into your frying pan, and make a little
pan sauce.
So I'm having fun as I'm doing this because
it, it gets your mind sort of spinning. If
you make a dreadful mistake, you have only
yourself to -
[laughter]
you eat it anyway. [laughs]
So what if the sauce curdled? And you learn
something from it so that next time you're
a little more careful with the flame or you
don't put ice cold milk in and it's that kind
of thing.
Also the other positive things are that, that
it's much less expensive. You can buy a whole
little chicken and you can, you use it probably
in five or six ways.
I always go in and get the, the packet of
giblets 'cause I love a chicken liver and
make a little shirred egg and chicken liver
lunch for myself.
And there's the neck and the giblets and you,
-- I either freeze them until I have a big
pot of them or if I need just a little bit
of broth, put that in a pot and boil it up;
and then you have some cold chicken for lunch
and then you can make some of those wonderful
old fashioned dishes, I think of them.
One is just minced chicken on toast with nice
flavors in it; some cream and maybe some Madeira
and some shallots and a little herbs. And
it's so simple. Or you can have fun and make
yourself [ ].
I remember there was a restaurant called The
Chicken Divan. No, the restaurant was called
The Divan when I was growing up and one of
their specialties was a chicken Divan which
was broccoli on the bottom of a dish and then
a lovely cream sauce on the chicken and parmesan
cheese and baked all together.
And that's very easy to make if you've got
a piece of leftover chicken and your cream
sauce is in the fridge. You have that ready
in 10 minutes. And then bake it.
So that, that, that is a large part of the
fun too of, of feeling, "Well, I've probably
spent half of what my neighbor's spending
with that take out that she's eating."
And also, and I think this is a, a very important
factor, we're much more aware today of where
our food comes from and we care about it.
And we can take that little extra to buy something
organic and we don't have to eat things that
we don't know what's in them; all those ersatz
products and corn oil and stuff like that.
We're in charge of what we're eating and that
gives you a very, very good feeling. And it's
fun to go to farmer's markets and to stop
at some of the, the little stands all through
Manhattan; get to know; they see me coming
and they say, "Oh you want your blueberries"
or and my bananas or -
And it, supermarkets have become so lifeless;
nobody talks to you. I mean you don't have
that connection. So it's us to cultivate that
and feel that even when you're in New York
that you are in touch with, with the things
of the earth even when you're up on the ninth
floor. [laughs]
[laughter]
And so those, those, those are all some of
the, the, the pleasures that I find and in
doing this book, I wanted to make it very
personal.
I think that when you're in the kitchen, particularly
a young person starting out for the first
time, and most of us haven't learned at Grandma's
knee the way we used to in the past, and so
you need, you need to feel somebody's there
with you. And so I wanted that sense of a
voice in the kitchen.
And we don't have to be so compulsively fussy.
We've gone too far in that direction. I mean
recipes talk about in a bowl combine the first
mixture with the second mixture - we don't
call things what they are. I'd really, the
first time I came upon that I thought, "What's
my mixture?" And I looked, and up in the first
paragraph Step, 1, 2, 3, 4; you don't cook
that way.
I saw that the milk had been heated with a
little sugar so that becomes the first mixture?
I mean it, I wanna bring back into cookbooks
that sense of there's a person there who's
loving what she's doing and wants to share
it with you and you can talk back to her it
if doesn't work.
And so we had a lot of fun putting this together
and when we were thinking about the cover,
unfortunately I'm an editor at Knopf, and
also published by them, so I'm right on the
inside of things and can have a say in what
the cover should look like and the design.
But I, I was having lunch across the street
at a new restaurant that had opened and it
had a cheese soufflé; you don't see that
very often; 25 minute wait, but I had a chatty
author with me and the 25 minutes flew.
And in came this perfect little for one soufflé;
it was delicious. I was so excited by it;
I thought that's the cover. Because to me
it expresses everything I would want to set
it up. Pleasing yourself, making something
that's good to look at, delicious to eat,
putting to use some of these principles of,
I mean the cream sauce that I needed was right
in the, right in the freezer. And so we put,
we put that on the cover.
And then the young designer asked what this
background material was. And I said, "Well
it's just a kitchen towel, I have." She said,
"Bring it in." And so we have to get rid of
this and this -
[pause]
So she took the towel and used it for the
oldest ancillary material I'm telling, I'm
telling you about how, how to use up your
cheeses; how to buy them; how to keep them;
how to use up milk because you have to get
a whole quart of milk when all you want is
half a pint.
And incidentally I, I think I'm gonna start
a movement called 'Remember the Solos' or
'Remember The Single Cook' or something like
that.
[laughter]
And I once talked to a supermarket and I said,
"Why don't you just think of that single cook
and, and you could have a sticker on the outside
of your store saying, "We Cater To Singles."
I said, "You'd be inundated."
[laughter]
But they don't talk, they'd, they'd rather
have us waste food so you do buy too much
and so you have to think another way.
But to go back to this book. I also wanted
to kind of tell a few stories because I think
there's always a story in a recipe; it's always
where it came from and I'll just read you
one of these because -
[long pause]
"Once when I was up in Cambridge, Massachusetts
working all day non-stop with Julia Child,
as we often did, it was almost 11 p.m. when
she finally swept away the manuscript and
announced, 'We'll make dinner.'
[laughter]
And she turned to me and said, 'Judith, you
make a nice little potato dish while I fix
the meat.' Slightly unnerved I managed to
give rise to the occasion and put together
what I would call a fast stove top version
of the classic Potatoes Anna.
As I mashed some garlic and salt together
and smeared this between the layers of the
sliced potatoes, Julia was looking on a bit
skeptically and although I used lots of butter
- of which she always approved - it wasn't
clarified butter.
But when we sat down and she took her first
bite, she pronounced the potatoes delicious
and her husband Paul toasted me. I was in
cook's heaven."
[laughter]
So it's, it's dispersed with stories because
I think that way you get to know the person
who's guiding you and I guess that's, gives
you a sort of feeling of the book and the
impulse behind it and I just hope you all
have fun with it.
But have you got some questions?
[pause]
Oh you must have some questions.
>>Q: Hi there. Thank you so much for coming,
especially given the weather. But I was wondering
if in general, I've been told that sometimes
if you wanna cook for one and take a recipe
that was designed for four, that you could,
you really can't just quarter it, is that
true?
>>Judith Jones: I'm, I'm not following that
too well.
>>Q: If I wanted to take a recipe that was
designed for more than one person -
>>Judith Jones: Okay, yeah. Uh-hum.
>>Q: and make it for one, can I just half
it or quarter it, or are there some things
that don't translate?
>>Judith Jones: Yes, if you remember to half
and quarter the pan too.
[laughter]
You see what I mean?
>>Q: Uh-hum.
>>Judith Jones: I remember I did one of Lidia
Bastianich's dishes and I told her about it.
And she said, "Oh, but you, that wouldn't
be any good for one because you, you would,
all the liquid would boil away."
Well I did it in a small one portion pan and
the liquid didn't all disappear. You have
to adjust just a little bit. Watch it. And
I kinda keep notes, but that's the, the basic
principle to use the right size utensil for
the amount, the recipe you're cutting down.
>>Q: Thank you.
>>Q: Hi, I just wanted to know if you had
like a favorite recipe or is there something
in particular that you really enjoy cooking.
>>Judith Jones: A favorite recipe?
>>Q: Yeah, favorite recipe in your book. Do
you, is there, do you really like cooking
fish versus chicken and do you have a favorite
recipe?
>>Judith Jones: Well, I really only did recipes
that I love.
[laughter]
And it's hard to say a favorite. For one thing
I'm always working with new authors and I
learn from them, so I want to experiment with
that and right now my recipes I love the most
are ones I'm doing of Madhur Jaffrey who has
a book coming in the fall on Indian cooking
that she's really simplified so that it's
much easier for you and me to do it.
Having said that, I do sometimes get a yen
for something. And this happened with popovers.
And I thought, "You know I can't make a whole
pan full of popover's, they don't, they don't
keep, I mean they collapse out of - you have
to eat them hot from the oven."
And then I, I remembered this popover pan
that has separate units so that they don't
steam, but the air in the oven circulates.
And so I got myself those popovers pans and
I cut down the recipe so that, I think I made
just two. And that was so exciting. Just the
taste of the popover; and memories of childhood.
I think we're very attached to things we ate
as children and, and I've learned another
trick that, if you cut a slice in them so
they do deflate at least they aren't soggy
and you can warm the second, or the leftover
one in the oven the next day and it's pretty
good.
So you, you constantly find a way and you
feel so proud of yourself.
[laughter]
[pause]
>>Q: Thank you for coming. I would just love
to hear a little bit about your history and
your journey and kind of where you are today
versus, how you fell in love with cooking
and a little bit about that. That'd be great.
>>Judith Jones: Yeah. I will. I, it's, it's,
it's kind of all in the, the first book, 'The
Tenth Muse, My Life In Food', so I didn't
repeat that here.
But I don't know, I think I was born with
the right genes, I always just loved gravitating
to the kitchen and watching our cook Edie
with a big ceramic bowl and a wooden spoon.
I can still hear the plop of that cake batter
as she beat it in the big bowl and I would
ask her questions about what she ate when
she, what she served her boyfriend over the
weekend when she went back to Harlem.
And I mean it, it seemed, it seemed a whole
world out there because our cooking was pretty,
pretty good straightforward plain English
cooking; no garlic. [laughs]
[laughter]
So, but I, I just had this in my genes. I
loved to cook for my dog when I was a little
girl too. That's before we had canned dog
food.
And so I pursued this and was, went to Paris
when I was 24 years old, just on a summer
holiday because I wanted perhaps a bubble.
And I stayed instead of three weeks, I stayed
for three and a half years. And, and that's
a whole story in itself.
But I tried different things. I even had a
French boyfriend who helped this one little
restaurant in the Countesses apartment and
had all kinds of adventures.
But most of all what I learned was how food
is such a part of French life and what a good
time they have with it. Now they talk about
it and take the whole family to the market
and go to the charcuterie for this and the
patisserie for this the boulangerie for this
and the time is, is time spent on something
they love. So that it, it, it was a revelation
to me.
And when I came back, which was 1951, it seemed
sort of a wasteland here. I mean we didn't
have even fresh mushrooms, fresh herbs in
our supermarkets and the, the garlic you could
get came in a little box; little desiccated
cloves as though it mustn't touch anything
else. [laughs]
[laughter]
And I, I just found it hard and there, there
wasn't a book that really taught me. I had
learned from asking, asking questions and
trial and error.
But I really wanted to get into it and preserve
those good French dishes and fortunately I
had just been about a year at Knopf and I
was working mostly on French translations,
and along came this huge tome which turned
out to be 'Mastering the Art of French Cooking'.
And it was as though it had been written for
me. I felt it was just an answer to my prayers.
Here it was; all of it.
So I had to convince Knopf. But fortunately
old Mr. Knopf was a, he was a wine and food
society kind of food connoisseur; never go
in the kitchen, but you, you appreciate from
outside.
And I think he just finally ended up let Mrs.
Jones have her chance and it was, the rest
is history; Julia got on. I mean the book
was very, very well received, but it was when
she got on television and she was such a natural.
And I think she just awakened America to the
pleasures of cooking and to get rid of all
that sort of Puritan ethic and enjoy slapping
the little chicken. Somebody asked her why
she massaged the chicken and she said, "Well,
I think he likes it." [laughs]
[laughter]
And she's so spontaneous and fun. It was,
it was magical; it just caught fire. And isn't
it interesting that with this film 'Julie
and Julia', it's catching fire again.
We have sold so many copies of 'Mastering
the Art' since that movie came out.
So good things happen; you just wait long
enough. But I felt if Julia does this for
French cooking I wanna find somebody who can
teach us Middle Eastern cooking, Chinese cooking,
Spanish cooking, Indian cooking.
So I really went in search of new writers
who, and very often they were women who had,
had to leave their homeland when they were
young and were deeply attached to the roots,
wanted that connection through food and wrote
so beautifully about it.
And so I, that's how it all developed. [laughs]
And I could go on and on, but that's, that's
enough of a, of an outline at least.
[pause]
>>Commentator: Somebody else?
>>unidentified voice: Yes.
[pause]
>>Q: Can you talk a little bit more about
your relationship with Julia Child and some
more interesting stories?
[laughter]
>>Judith Jones: About my, my relationship
with her or my, my working with her?
>>Q: Uh-hum.
>>Judith Jones: Yeah. Yeah. Well it's interesting
because probably most of you have seen 'Julie
and Julia' and I think Meryl Streep gives
a wonderful portrayal of that lust for life
and the pleasure and all of that and the very,
very intimate and supportive relationship
with Paul, her husband.
But I think there's one thing missing and
that is that Julia was absolutely dedicated
to making Americans cook better [laughs]
[laughter]
and she came back from France with this mission.
And nothing would, nothing would stop her.
You know the book was turned down by the publisher
in Boston that had taken an option on it and
instead of just boo-hooing about it and saying,
"Well, well I'm no good.", it would just -- fired
her determination to get this message across
and not to compromise it.
And little things like, I remember I asked
her once, we were doing a [casavie] for the
second volume of Mastering and I said, "I
can't find a, a real garlic sausage." You
know it, it was pretty much the American bland
kind of sausage and, that you could get. And
I said, "Could you give a little formula for
it and people will make their own. Why not?"
"Good idea," said Julia.
Well I went up to Cambridge and walked into
her kitchen, she, and she had posted on a
whole wall her findings going back to old
charcuterie manuals and trying the different
proportions, and finally at the end was her
version and she said, "This is it" or something
like that. I say, "Julia" and she said, "It
wasn't hard. It's just like making a hamburger."
[laughs]
[laughter]
But that, that, that absolute dedication and
she was not, she wasn't so adverse to change,
but she was very particular about whether
the Cuisinart would really do this or this
and you mustn't put potatoes in it because
they turn to glue. But you can make beautiful,
beautiful things of purees and - I, I always
used to come home and buy a new piece of equipment
after I'd been up visiting Julia -
[laughter]
So she had that [ ] when she said to me that,
"Judith you and I were born at the right time."
Yes, but she acted on it and so it was a very
much a force of personality.
>>Q: So what was your reaction when you heard
that Julie Powell was, [clearing throat] excuse
me, cooking through 'Mastering the Art of
French Cooking' strictly in order; all within
a year. Did that seem adventurous? Did is
seem a little daft? Were you perhaps inspired
to try it yourself with some other book, anything
like that?
>>Judith Jones: Well my reaction was first
I wanted to, somebody told me about it and
I wanted to see what she was doing. If you've
seen the movie, it's, it's a movie version.
[laughter]
But I was going to go out and see her and
also talk about rights and using Julia's recipes
and just things like that. I mean sort of
a business trip. And Julia was on the West
Coast and she said, "Well, we'd better look
at the blog." So we looked at the blog and
we both decided that it wasn't anything Julia
should have anything to do with principally
because I think Julia felt, "You can't be
serious talking about food when you have a
vocabulary of four letter words to describe
things." And that was about what it was.
So she, we just thought let her have her blog;
let's stay away from it. So that was that
I called up and cancelled the dinner party
and -
[laughter]
or didn't come to the dinner party. But I,
I think it's, it's understandable. A lot of
people come away from that and think, "Why
was Julia so mean to Julie?" Julia was not
mean to, she was a most supportive and generous
person, but you had to be a serious cook.
She talked, she had a word for those who weren't
and she called them the "flimsies."
[laughter]
Well I think she just didn't take Julie seriously.
Does that answer pretty much the question?
Yeah.
I have to be careful saying this and I'm not,
I'm not trying to demean Julie; she had her
own agenda. But they were kind of worlds apart.
[pause]
Also I think that I give credit to Nora Ephron
because I think she had a wonderful concept
in putting this movie together to have the
different generations of the Julia's and the
different attitudes and I think Julia does
come out as the one you wanna root for. [laughs]
[laughter]
[pause]
>>Commentator: Well Judith, thank you so much.
>>Judith Jones: Thank you all for coming.
[applause]
Fortunately you didn't have to get through
this -